[Música]
a 22 días de las presidenciales en eeuu
donald trump retorno a la contienda con
un multitudinario acto de campaña en
florida donde dijo sentirse poderoso e
inmune al virus
su rival yo bailén también se prepara
para regresar a ese estado clave
mientras que en washington siguen las
audiencias rumbo a la confirmación de
amy con ibarreta en la corte de suprema
enlazamos a la capital
países europeos ajustan medidas y
adoptan criterios comunes en las
ciudades donde impactan los rebrotes de
coronavirus el gobierno francés prepara
nuevas restricciones en italia y en
república checa se cierran bares
restaurantes y colegios para frenar el
nivel de contagios y alemania- debate
limitaciones a viajes en zonas de riesgo
jornada de protestas en américa latina'
en rechazo al día en que se conmemora la
llegada de los españoles al continente
mientras que en mexico un fuerte cerco
policial impidió el derribo de una
estatua de cristóbal colón' en bolivia
le lanzaron pintura indígenas en ecuador
y en chile- exigieron la reivindicación
de sus derechos ancestrales
hola como estan saludamos de vuelta a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria hoy que es martes sean
bienvenidos
empezamos en eeuu donde el presidente de
donald trump realizó su primer acto de
campaña tras haber sido diagnosticado
con kobe 19 la casa blanca dijo que el
mandatario no puede contagiar a nadie al
dar negativo en una prueba y trump
reiteró a la multitud que él ya es
inmune al virus
bardem por su parte estuvo en ohio
haciendo un llamado al bipartidismo a
tres semanas de las elecciones ambos
candidatos buscan conquistar el voto en
estados pendulares es decir aquellos
donde no gana siempre el mismo partido
andrés meza muñoz tiene los detalles
de vuelta a la carrera por la casa
blanca repartiendo mascarillas el
presidente de donald trump llegó a
florida para presumir su primer acto de
campaña fuera de washington después de
haber sido diagnosticado con kobe 19 su
médico informó que dio negativo en una
nueva prueba de coronavirus y agregó que
no puede contagiar a otros pero el
mandatario le dio otra interpretación
que dicen que soy inmune
me siento tan poderoso entraré a esa
multitud y besaré a todos
y dicen que eres inmune no sé por cuánto
tiempo algunas personas dicen que de por
vida donald trump llega en busca de
consolidar su victoria florida aporta 29
de los 270 votos electorales para poder
ganar la presidencia es uno de los que
más otorgan todo el país pero es
reconocido como un estado pendular es
decir que no se inclina siempre por el
mismo partido y por ello los candidatos
se esfuerzan en cortejar a sus votantes
joe biden también estará allí pero antes
llegó hasta ohio otro estado pendular el
candidato demócrata ha aumentado su
publicidad a medida que trump ha
reducido su presencia
ohio aporta 18 electores y aunque barack
obama los ganó todos en 2008 y 2012
trump se quedó con ellos en 2016
necesitamos revivir el espíritu del
bipartidismo en el país no habrá estados
azules ni estados rojos conmigo es un
eeuu trabajador demócratas y
republicanos paulo x ambos candidatos se
mueven a un ritmo marcado por lo que
reflejan las encuestas pero solo tienen
tres semanas antes de que se descubra
quién ocupará la oficina
los próximos cuatro años
seguimos en eeuu y es que después de un
día dedicado a las declaraciones de
apertura e miconi barret la nominada a
la corte suprema por trump enfrentará
este martes preguntas de los integrantes
del comité judicial del senado en el
segundo día de audiencias del proceso de
confirmación para ocupar la vacante
dejada por ruth báder ginsburg ayer
barrett expresó puntos de vista en
desacuerdo con la difunta jueza el
senado encabezado por republicanos busca
una votación rápida antes del día de las
elecciones para los demócratas la
nominación debería realizarse después de
ese 3 de noviembre es por ello que
enlazamos con diana castañeda nuestra
corresponsal en washington buenos días
por allá diana en la capital la ley de
cuidado de salud asequible y los
derechos al aborto se abordaron ayer que
tan tenso se vio el comienzo de las
audiencias
hola buenos días fue muy tenso en la
verdad porque muchos de los miembros
demócratas de este comité en el senado
cuestionaron a barrett sobre sus
posiciones frente a obama que oa la ley
de cuidado en salud a bajo costo y es
que básicamente los demócratas temen que
al ser confirmada barrer la balanza
entre los miembros liberales y los más
conservadores al interior del tribunal
supremo- cambie y los republicanos
intenten acabar con este seguro de salud
que protege a personas con
preexistencias médicas como por ejemplo
diabetes o cáncer y es que la prueba más
importante vendrá para este ley en
cuidado de salud después de las
elecciones tan sólo siete días después
de las elecciones cuando la corte
suprema- escuche los argumentos de una
demanda que han liderado cerca de 18
estados todos los republicanos en cabeza
de texas para que el tribunal supremo-
derogue acabe permanentemente con obama
care así que este es uno de los temas
más importantes que vimos en la
discusión el día de ayer en las
audiencias dianas se podría abordar el
como barrett manejaría las disputas
electorales mientras trump sigue
señalando fraude electoral que se espera
por hoy
definitivamente este es uno de los temas
que se abordarán durante estas
discusiones y es que la confirmación de
barrett será muy importante en caso de
que después de estas elecciones
presidenciales alguno de los dos
candidatos solicite un reconteo y se
pueda registrar algo similar a lo que
ocurrió entre bush y alcohol donde el
tribunal supremo sería el encargado de
decidir quién es el presidente de los
eeuu y los demócratas han dicho en
varias oportunidades que precisamente
ese es el objetivo del presidente de
donald trump que a menos de un mes de
las elecciones e iluminó a barrer y
espera que sea confirmada en el senado
también se esperan críticas frente a
como barre tiene una opinión religiosa
muy fuerte que podría no ser digamos
objetivo al momento de tomar decisiones
frente a la libertad religiosa de los
estadounidenses bien diana castañeda
muchas gracias por tu reporte seguiremos
pendientes contigo nuestra corresponsal
en washington bonos con información de
la pandemia y es que justo cuando europa
reporta más de 7 millones
casos en medio de la segunda ola de
contagios algunos países indicaron que a
partir de este martes entrarán en vigor
nuevas medidas para controlar el rebrote
países bajos registró la primera muerte
del mundo por reinfección de kobe 19
entretanto la organización mundial de la
salud señaló que lograr la inmunidad de
rebaño en este continente no era una
opción para mitigar la enfermedad
sebastián espinoza nos tiene el informe
con un poco más de 776 mil contagios por
1.019 y un promedio de 16.000 nuevos
casos en las últimas 48 horas el
gabinete del presidente francés emmanuel
macrón se reúne para fijar nuevas
estrategias y estaría analizando
extender los confinamientos sectorizados
en varias regiones que el curso esquiva
está aumentando lentamente y de forma
masiva y justo como con otras
enfermedades a veces piensas que tienes
tiempo para mitigarlas pero al final es
una carrera contrarreloj y es ahí donde
estamos estamos en una carrera
contrareloj complementó
el número de hospitalizaciones superó
las 1500 el pasado lunes un récord que
no se daban desde el 27 de mayo la
situación no es diferente en otros
lugares de europa en italia que tiene en
el momento una medida de casos diarios
de 5500 se anunció que bares y
restaurantes deben cerrar a medianoche y
se prohíbe en los partidos de
aficionados de deporte de contacto
además de las fiestas privadas son lo
perfectamente de actor estoy en acuerdo
con el gobierno porque nadie puede saber
cuán malo es este virus así que es mejor
ser cauteloso y actuar a tiempo
y motos en precisamente una medida
similar en república checa que además se
extiende las restricciones al cierre
inmediato de todos los colegios este
país fue uno de los más exitosos en
contención de la pandemia por cada
100.000 habitantes
alemania cuenta este martes con más de
4.100 casos en medio de un fuerte debate
por la prohibición a los viajeros de las
zonas de riesgo del país de pernoctar en
su territorio el ascenso de casos en
europa sigue en aumento imparable a
pesar de las fuertes medidas de
bioseguridad
en china las autoridades han realizado
en dos días tres millones de pruebas en
qingdao ciudad de 9 millones de
habitantes donde se lleva a cabo una
campaña masiva de diagnósticos tras
haber descubierto un foco de contagios y
es que un rebrote de 12 casos
confirmados de coronavirus interrumpió
la racha de 57 días impositivos locales
en el país asiático esto a pesar de que
al momento todos los contagios están
relacionados con un mismo hospital
nosotros temas y es que ayer 12 de
octubre miles de personas protestaron en
américa latina' en el día en el que se
conmemora la llegada de los españoles al
continente en méjico un fuerte de
control policial con una barricada y un
centenar de agentes prohibió el derribo
de una estatua de cristóbal colón en la
capital por parte de diversos colectivos
que rechazan el colonialismo tres días
antes las autoridades ya habían retirado
otra estatua de colón presuntamente por
labores de mantenimiento el mar y ángulo
nos cuenta cómo se manifestaron otros
pueblos originarios de latinoamérica
[Música]
como un día de luto describieron cientos
de manifestantes la conmemoración del 2
de octubre en las calles de la capital
de chile indígenas mapuches se unieron a
líderes sociales en reclamo de respeto
por la diversidad cultural en el marco
de esta cuestionada fecha que recuerda
la llegada de cristóbal colón a américa
en el año 1492 y lo que en chile se
vivió como una manifestación en ecuador
se tradujo en un abierto rechazo por
parte de los grupos indígenas hermanos y
hermanas en todo el mundo organizaciones
de todo el mundo expresan que no hay
nada que celebrar
que fue un gran genocidio creo que el
genocidio más grande que se ha visto en
los pueblos indígenas de la tierra para
evitar que fuera derribada por los
manifestantes que se esperaban en el
cumplimiento de esta fecha en ciudad de
mexico la estatua de cristóbal colón fue
retirada en la nación azteca conocida
por ser una de las más críticas contra
el pasado colonial español el presidente
se refirió a la conmemoración de esta
jornada e insistió en su propuesta de
que sean ofrecidas disculpas a los
pueblos afectados para que el año
próximo
se lleven a cabo estas ceremonias
para ofrecer disculpas a los pueblos
originarios y hacer el compromiso de la
no repetición
que nunca jamás se vuelvan a cometer
atrocidades para el saqueo
no al colonialismo
no al sometimiento en la víspera
ciudadanos repudiaron la creación de
monumentos a líderes españoles no está
de acuerdo en tener este tipo de
monumentos en la calle porque pienso que
representan represión o en los últimos
meses incluso las protestas del
movimiento blacks life matter abordaron
el rechazo al colonialismo al motivar el
retiro de las estatuas de colom y entre
otros personajes de la época nos vamos a
vietnam y es que tras las fuertes
lluvias que en los últimos días han
provocado inundaciones y
desprendimientos de tierra al menos 28
personas han muerto y otras 12 están
desaparecidas las lluvias que azotan
desde hace casi una semana el centro del
país han inundado según las autoridades
más de 130 mil casas ha afectado más de
4.000 hectáreas de cultivos que han
provocado cuantiosos daños en carreteras
de la región se esperan más
precipitaciones en los próximos días
leon mantiene más cambiaron la página y
nos vamos a perú y es que machu picchu
fue abierto solamente para el ingreso de
un turista japonés que permaneció
atrapado siete meses debido a las
restricciones de la pandemia les
contamos la historia sobre esta peculiar
visita a uno de los puntos turísticos
más importantes de latinoamérica
el sueño de 10 y está acá llama de
recorrer las ruinas de machu picchu se
cumplió este turista japonés que
permaneció atrapado por la pandemia en
perú durante siete meses logró a conocer
este paraje ancestral con un permiso
especial de las autoridades y se
convirtió en el primero en visitarlo
tras el levantamiento de las
restricciones por la emergencia
sanitaria tu sur este tour es realmente
asombroso gracias por dejarme ver esto
aunque la propagación del brote de kobe
19 impidió que usara el pase que había
comprado para entrar en marzo a la
ciudad inca nada pudo impedir que su
estadía en una localidad en las faldas
de las montañas cercanas a este antiguo
poblado andino terminará con su ascenso
al santuario que según cifras oficiales
fue visitado por más de un millón de
turistas internacionales en 2019 todos
los japoneses
ha ingresado junto con nuestro jefe de
parque el impacto de la pandemia en
territorio peruano afectó a decenas de
ciudadanos que como takayama no pudieron
retornar a sus lugares de origen debido
al cierre de fronteras en la nación que
tiene la mayor tasa de mortalidad por
cada 100.000 habitantes de acuerdo con
datos de la universidad johns hopkins
y finalizamos con información deportiva
y es que comienza la segunda fecha de
las eliminatorias sudamericanas y la
región se prepara para una sola jornada
de emoción con todos los 5 encuentros
bolivia y argentina abre en la fecha
ecuador se enfrentará después a uruguay
por su parte venezuela y paraguay se
miden en un duelo de países que no
pudieron ganar en la primera fecha perú
recibe a brasil en la repetición de la
última final de la copa américa y chile
se mide ante colombia en la capital
santiago para cerrar la noche
y así llegamos al final siga con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]